oh rien en effet les événements du
cambodge ont encore élargi le fossé qui
sépare les frères ennemis
moscou et pékin l'ancien régime
cambodgien de polpot soutenu par les
chinois a été renversé par l'armée
vietnamienne qui bénéficie d'un puissant
appui soviétique
la nouvelle guerre du cambodge marque
donc l'affrontement par pays satellites
interposés entre la chine populaire et
l'union soviétique
en cinq jours les troupes de hanoï ont
chassé le régime des khmers rouges
un régime qui aurait exterminé plus de
deux millions de cambodgiens en quatre
ans dans les camps de réfugiés qui
bordent la frontière cambodgienne en
thaïlande
des milliers d'hommes et de femmes
espèrent rentrer au pays pour la
première fois de nombreux détails ont
été révélés sur l'enfer des quatre
années de régime khmer rouge
un reportage de notre envoyé spécial en
thaïlande jean-louis burgat 400 km à
l'est de bangkok sur la frontière
cambodgienne l'un des 15 camps pour ceux
qui ont réussi à échapper aux massages
7500 personnes ici une majorité d'hommes
parmi les derniers arrivés parce que
depuis un an
de l'autre côté de la frontière les
femmes et les enfants n'ont plus la
force nécessaire pour tenter le voyage
la plupart des groupes ont perdu la
moitié de leurs membres tués par les
khmers rouges lorsqu'ils étaient
découverts mais plus souvent morts
d'épuisement et de fin lorsqu'ils ont
réussi à passer les hommes en général
tiennent le coup ce n'est pas toujours
le cas pour les femmes et c'est encore
beaucoup plus difficile pour les rares
enfants lorsque les parents ont tenté la
fuite avec eux
vous pouvez lui demander quand est-ce
qu'elle a franchi la frontière le 4 le 4
janvier
pourquoi est ce qu'elle est partie de
villageois étaient morts beaucoup nom de
quoi - bell et y arriver qu'est-ce qu'il
a son bébé par le bébé un marasme
typiques comme vous avez vu aux biens
fera sans doute c'est le la dénutrition
total et ce qu'elle dit aussi c'est que
son village avait 700 personnes et dans
deux mois il est réduit à 500 personnes
à 200 personnes qui sont morts en
l'espace de deux mois et à doite rahmati
que tu racontes là on a eu par les
hommes
la même chose le même témoignage en dix
ans les gens les enfants sont
spécialement en train de mourir un
village données nutrition de diarrhées
de descente et il n'y a plus deux mais
tellement ya plus rien du tout
parmi les habitants du camp beaucoup
d'intellectuels d'instituteurs de
fonctionnaires principales cibles des
épurations successives du régime khmer
rouge
jusqu'à présent la plupart de ces
réfugiés qui voulait retourner un jour
au cambodge avait peur de parler
aujourd'hui la fin de la terreur de
l'autre côté de la frontière les laisse
plus libres et ils peuvent pour la
première fois raconté les quatre années
pendant lesquelles le cambodge s'est
coupé du monde avant 1975 et est
professeur de l'enseignement secondaire
dans les cd plus que s'est-il passé lors
de l'arrivée des khmers rouges pour vous
après la chute du régime ben ali
toutes les poupées noires war la
campagne institut l'enseignement
primaire et qu'avez vous fait au moment
de l'arrivée des khmers rouges au moment
de la chute de [ __ ] j'étais en prison
ce travail aux champs qu'est ce que vous
aviez comme salaire ou qu'est-ce que
vous donnez à manger
il n'y a plus de salaire il ya sûrement
des rations servières ne repas pas jour
à 12 heures et à 10 heures
l'histoire les femmes revivre avec les
hommes et travaillent séparément et les
petits enfants
il remettra et regroupe dans un endroit
travaille fort et là on travaille comme
des adultes
quand j'arrive dans mon village il y en
a quatre freins 1100 personnes
et lorsque vous êtes parti lorsque vous
avez fui le reste et combien il ne reste
que à peu près à seissan et sincèrement
alors où sont passés les autres
les autres sont morts de la fin de l'an
le malade de la maladie a du travail le
travail forcé et le massacre
massacre qu'est ce que ça veut dire le
massacre samir et les khmers rouges
tu les villas les villageois en groupe
dix ou vingt personnes cherchent à
chaque fois j'avais beaucoup de morts
l'exécution a à peu près de trois cent
quatre mois à la distance de 2 km de mon
grillage
parce que ses camarades ne sont pas
encore en faire et comment était-il tué
à l'aller aujourd'hui ces hommes qui
veulent rentrer au pays sont entre le
marteau et l'enclume vivre sous la loi
de l'ennemi héréditaire ou le combattre
aux côtés des anciens bourreaux depuis
la vie